so just do great work although i'm not
sure about ed sheeran in that santa
claus shorts thing yeah we don't want to
see your legs flying with a snowman and
that is actually part of the very same
story that i'm narrating this evening
this is a very popular children's book
from the 1980s well there you go wait is
ed sharon going to be there no oh [ __ ]
the story's been around since the early
show you were asking me to for a little
snippet yes so this little boy
makes a snowman in the middle of the
night he wakes up tiptoes to the window
looks down at the snowman
and while the boy is looking at him the
snowman
moves
actually starts walking towards the boy
he stops and raises his hat and walks
forward right up to the boy
and you have to come down to the
pinecrest academy
to catch the rest of the story
serious
okay all right that's it
yes 7 30. what a great team
it is it's really cool a lot of fun
excellent yeah wow
you had me i was leaning in there you go
come on
we're on the edge of our feet and jeff
newman conducting the henderson symphony
volunteer musicians and a lot of fun